it's a monday edition of the pft pm
podcast and we're going to get right to
it it's hall of fame head coach
member of nbc's football night in
america and one of the most influential
voices in all of sports tony dungy
joining me now good afternoon coach
how's everything hey i'm doing well mike
good to be with you even though we have
to do it virtually here it's always good
to be with you yeah you know the thing
that i like about this shift to the
virtual meetings
so many of the interviews we do now
are done like this and you can actually
see the person instead of doing them by
phone it's revolutionized the industry
and i think the audience appreciates
being able to actually see the person
not just hear their voices
yeah and i'll tell you what mike i i
have you know you have to do what you
can do and it's been kind of a blessing
to me i've gotten to talk to so many
people over the last five weeks uh
because you don't have to go somewhere
and be there i've spoken to the
us naval academy graduates the usa
wrestling team in colorado springs and
it's just you know you have to get used
to this format but it's been great it's
been awesome
and the format's been there it's been
available but it took something like
this for it to explode in utilization to
the point where i think it's going to be
commonplace whenever we get to the new
normal whatever the new normal may be
one year two years three years or longer
from now i feel like this
zoom or whatever technology whatever
specific platform will be so much more
common in the way we communicate and
interact than it ever was before
i agree with you we've done family
talks
with cousins nephews you know
grandparents and done it and had 12 15
people on things that we've never done
before uh so
it's something we're getting used to and
i think it's going to be great i really
do
well the last time we had a conversation
like this coach you were on the phone i
was up in my tv studio when we were
talking about
the
the regression
in minority hiring of coaches and
general managers the performance in
recent years which has seen a
significant step backward and your
thoughts on what needed to be done to
move it forward
and since then
we've seen at least for what we know so
far a significant proposal that would
change that and my understanding is a
lot of things have been happening behind
the scenes and you've been involved in
that can you kind of walk us through
what's happened since january to get to
where we are now
yeah the fritz pollard alignment
the prince pollard association had kind
of aligned with several other people to
put together a task force to come up
with some ideas that we could present to
the diversity committee
that would help the situation we went to
indianapolis we met with the diversity
committee had several kind of conference
calls back and forth
we made some proposals and the diversity
committee i guess is now ready to on
tuesday tomorrow uh have a couple of
proposals to be voted on so a lot of
things have taken place i think the
biggest thing mike was the actual
broadcast of the draft i think when
people saw that and you saw the decision
makers and their families just one after
another after another the draftees and
their families and just that contrast i
think it gave a visual picture to what
everyone was seeing
now the proposals were reported on
friday the most significant of which the
ability of teams to increase their draft
standing in round three by six spots if
they hire a minority coach 10 spots if
they hire a minority gm those
adjustments come the year after the
hiring not in the year of the hiring
there are other incentives tied to
allowing coaches to leave for
coordinator jobs quarterback coach jobs
elsewhere
and look there's been a mixed reaction
to
that
i see both sides of it i understand that
given where the nfl currently is
something needed to happen and something
significant needed to happen give me
your thoughts personally on
whether this is the right move whether
it maybe doesn't go far enough or
whether it goes too far
yeah i i think that this is definitely
something that that's been
looked at and said we've got to do
something drastic
in my mind this is drastic i don't
personally think it's the right thing to
do but i think it should spur some uh
really consideration and some
communication and conversation and
people say okay this might not be it but
maybe we can do that
um i do like the first proposal i was in
favor of it letting coaches go even out
of a contract if they're going to get a
promotion that's going to help the
supply part of it um i i just have never
been in favor of
rewarding people for doing the right
thing
and and so i think there's going to be
some unintended consequences to me it's
almost like the past interference rule
yeah we need to do something i don't
know if this is exactly it we need to
keep working until we find out what that
best thing is to do hey coach and i
agree with you they've been unable to
get people to do the right thing via the
rooney rule and we see so many occasions
where it looks like maybe the spirit of
the rule if not in some cases the letter
of the rule is being violated we've
talked about how teams just use it as a
check the box and do what we're going to
do anyway okay we've complied with the
rooney rule now we can go hire the guy
we've wanted to hire all along the guy
we decided six months ago we're gonna
hire
um and there's nothing they can really
do about it so they're flipping it from
potentially punitive to potentially
rewarding to do something that as you
said should be the right thing to do and
should be done without any type of
reward
um
what what would you do instead
of
of that or or is there is there really
nothing you can do when it comes to
hiring you just have to create an
environment where you hope people do the
right thing and encourage them to do the
right thing and have neither a
punishment nor a reward if they fail to
do the right thing
that's where i've fallen this i don't
think you can legislate uh
the right thing i don't think you can
legislate fairness um so to me you have
to do other things to kind of try to
create that my suggestion was if i were
the commissioner i would get every owner
to sit down and write out
exactly what he's looking for his
qualities that he's looking for in a
head coach a general manager personnel
department all of those top level
positions even if i'm not looking right
now
spell it out so that when that time does
come i have a blueprint to kind of fall
back on and and i think that would
really help number one it would help
owners think about
who i have in that position right now
if
i'm tempted to make a change and i spell
out here's the five or six things that i
really want and i look at the coach i
have now and he is that well maybe i
don't need to make a change maybe that
tells me what i'm looking for
but i think more than anything getting
owners to really spell it out then you
can come and say okay if that's what
you're looking for here are some people
who
fall into that category here's people
you can look at and we'll have a much
better way of going right now it is so i
think so many owners
at least the ones that i talk to when
they're in the process they really don't
know what they're looking for we talk
about the rooney rule i always go back
to dan rooney in 2006
and he had a lot of qualified people a
lot of good coaches on his staff when
bill cower retired he could have hired
dick lebeau he could have hired
wisenhunt russ grimm he had just had
bruce arians a lot of people that he
knew but he said you know what these
guys that's not my formula what i've
always looked for is young communicative
defensive coaches
that have a future that have 20 years
ahead of them that's what i'm looking
for and he ended up finding mike tomlin
but
the easy way would have just been to say
i don't really know what i'm looking for
i've got good people here let me just
hire russ grimm because we've won and
he's great
or let me hire ken wizanon he worked
with the quarterbacks and he's great
but dan said no i have a way of doing
this and it worked out pretty well and i
think that's the kind of thinking that
we've got to stimulate and you know it's
funny i think part of it also comes from
the pride that owners naturally have and
it's human nature
when you're not quite sure what to do
but you don't want to ask for help you
don't want to expose to anyone on the
outside i really don't know what to do
here and we see the nfl connect teams
with search firms all the time when
they're looking for someone i i think
what you're saying suggests maybe
that whole process begins one step back
when you first start thinking about
maybe making a change that's when you
get someone from the outside to help you
identify what you're looking for
identify the factors because as you said
there's a chance that the end result may
be
i'm fine with the guy i have i'm not
going to make a change at this time and
if you do make a change you're going to
be doing it from the standpoint of what
you're looking for by way of qualities
not hey this guy's available he won a
super bowl
i need to go get him
yeah i'll tell you a story relating to
my own experience
about that whole thing and it's the
process of picking people um jeff lurie
when he bought the philadelphia eagles
he was making the change in the mid 90s
hiring head coaches he interviewed me
and i remember asking him
what are you looking for that was my
last question what do you want in a head
coach and we talked about it and he said
a few things that he was looking for
and i told my wife i think i'm gonna get
this job because
what he described is me
and everything that he said he wanted
i think i can deliver why didn't get the
job he ended up hiring ray rhodes
another african-american coach it wasn't
anything racial it wasn't this
he hired ray rhodes and
it lasted a few years but ray was not
what he described to me
then he hired andy rear
feet and i remember telling my wife and
i told jeff laurie at the owners meeting
now you've hired the exact person you
described you the things that you said
you want you hired him they had a long
and successful run
well then he
let andy go
and he hired chip kelly
my son played for chip kelly chip kelly
is brilliant he's smart he was a great
offensive innovator he was not what jeff
murray was describing so i'm thinking
well maybe he's changed his mind on what
he wants
it didn't work out didn't last long then
he hired doug peterson who is exactly
what he described to me 25 years ago
that he wanted
and it just really reinforced to me if
owners know what they want and they
are diligent in finding that person
then it'll work and you'll have better
outcomes
and one of the realities in the nfl with
32 different teams 32 different
operations there's a reason why
teams are changing coaches and general
managers on a regular basis sometimes
there is just
some form of dysfunction embedded in the
organization that prevents it from doing
what it needs to do from identifying the
factors that need to be identified and
then from acting
on the right factors if they happen to
put together a list of what they are
looking for
and you know you talk about the search
firms and you know how some teams are
using those again it's the same thing
you have to describe what you're looking
for i had another interview early on in
my career i was still an assistant coach
uh interviewed with the team
and
we got to the end of it and the owner
said he was looking for somebody to run
everything to kind of be the bill
parcells the head coach general manager
president was all going to be wrapped up
in one
that wasn't me
all i wanted to do was coach i didn't
feel like i was qualified to do that i
didn't want to be a gm so that job
wasn't for me some search firm could
have said hey tony dungy's the best
candidate out there and he's great and
he's this and that but for that
particular owner i wasn't the best
candidate because i didn't want to do
that so again it to me it comes down to
what are you looking for and then find
the best person to do that
and one of the other problems with the
proposal and we'll talk more in a minute
about where that proposal may be headed
the idea that the reward for a team that
makes
a minority hire whether a coach or a gm
is to move up in the draft well as you
move somebody up you move somebody else
down and it does work to the detriment
of the teams that
maybe already have a minority coach or
minority gm or both or teams that are
stable and aren't firing their coaches
or their gm's on a regular basis
so that's one of the things that i think
may be rubbing people the wrong way
there's an inherent detriment to
everyone else if you take one team and
say we're going to boost you up the
ladder
well not only that mike i've talked to
several uh
african-american coaches in in the
league right now to get their response
and here's there's three things that
they're worried about number one how
does this put me in my relationship with
the other coaches that i work with and
other white coaches are they thinking
i'm getting an advantage now number two
when that general manager or owner hires
me is he hiring me because he thinks i'm
the best person or is he hiring me to
move his draft choice up a little bit uh
and then the third thing is nobody feels
like
they want anything special an advantage
don't hire me and then say i'm going to
give you more draft choices later on
because you need help or you know and i
know that's not the reason why the
proposal is being put in i know that's
not
you know what they're driving at but
that's still the end result and so uh
there there's some things i think the
league needs to think about about this
proposal
yeah i spoke at length yesterday with
cyrus mary the co-founder of the fritz
pollard alliance and he describes it as
a diversity boost and that other
companies use something like it usually
it's in the form coach of bonuses for
senior management based upon diversity
performance and that's fine because it's
different from that inherently
competitive
32 teams everyone wanting to draft as
high as possible and get the best
possible picks and you are moving some
down moving some up and also and you're
touching on one of the concerns that
louis riddick shared with peter king in
football morning in america the idea
that as you walk through the door people
may be viewing you differently you are
undermined before you even start the job
because there's this sense that some may
have that the only reason you're getting
the job is because the team derives some
tangible benefit from hiring a minority
gm or coach
yeah and there there is i think the
league is looking and saying hey
punitive things haven't worked let's
look at incentives and maybe that's the
right way to go but i don't know if this
is the right incentive
so this is going to be voted on tomorrow
and
the people that i've talked to kind of
have a sense this is going to get passed
that it's something that the
commissioner wants it's something that
enough of the powerful owners want and i
don't sense a coordinated
pushback
to stop it from happening but if you had
a vote it sounds like your vote would be
no which i think
should speak volumes to anyone out there
who has a vote on tuesday on this
proposal
i
when i looked at it i didn't see how it
would pass a lot of people are telling
me that it will i think if it does pass
it'll end up being like the past
interference
review rule we'll see
in a little while some some unintended
consequences that will say gosh this
this might not be the best idea
now my understanding also coach is that
this proposal that's come to light
is part of what could be a broader
overhaul of the hiring process that it's
going to be more comprehensive that you
know peter king is advocated for a
shifting of when you actually can even
begin to hire coaches do you get the
sense that there may be something else
coming down the pipeline that would be
even more
broad and more comprehensive than what
they've already proposed
well this task force we did present a
lot of
ideas and a lot of ways to make the
hiring process better one of those was
delaying the process letting everybody
get through the playoffs slowing things
down that was dan rooney's whole idea
about the rooney rule not the fact that
you're interviewing minority candidates
necessarily but slow the process down
take
take your time doing it and i
i think that's something that needs to
be done and uh we had you know made a
lot of proposals i don't know what will
happen with this obviously the way it
has
gone in these last seven eight years uh
has not really helped the league in
terms of diversity hiring
well the intent seems to be
in a good place and i feel like
that the attention of the right people
has been secured the question now is
how do you take that
that desire
to
encourage teams to do the right thing
and craft it into something that is
practical that is proper
and that gets you to the right place the
right way like anthony lin said the
chargers head coach sometimes you do the
wrong thing trying to do the right thing
the goal is
they want to do the right thing
and
let's hope they get nudged toward the
right path
and it sounds like there's hope that
that'll happen but this proposal would
at least in the short term not be the
right path
you know and that's uh when when i was
coaching we you'd have these owners
meetings the head coaches would be there
the gm's everybody would be together
you'd get these proposals you talk about
them the owner has a chance to talk with
this head coach with his gm
and
hash it out and then they'd go back and
vote well now apparently that's not
going to be the case it's a virtual
meeting zoom meeting with just the
owners so i don't know i think it would
be better to get
conversation about this uh before they
vote on it hopefully these owners have
done that and had some conversations
with their coaches
before tomorrow but i think you're right
whether it's what they're going to do as
a replacement for past interference for
replay review which is going to be tough
to hash out through a zoom connection or
these deeper issues about how to best
handle and best address this legitimate
and genuine desire to improve the
minority hiring practices
look the hiring cycle doesn't start next
week that's one of the things that's
kind of confusing to me
maybe that can be tabled until a time
when everyone can get together when
there can be face-to-face discussions
and and there's just something organic
about having everyone in the same room
or all of the owners present and hashing
it out that way then doing it remotely
especially if more and more pictures pop
up on your computer screen you get a lot
you lose track of who all's involved and
who isn't so maybe the the smart thing
to do
is is to have a conversation tomorrow
table it for now
until a time when they can all get the
same room and really figure out what
they want to do coach i know you're busy
a couple of other things real quickly
before i let you go there was a rash of
arrests over the weekend two of them
arose from incidents last week then two
other incidents that happened and one of
the reasons it stands out is players
have done i think a very good job in
recent years of staying out of trouble
away from
the field
i think one of the realities this year
with no off season program no
opportunity to have development meetings
to reinforce messages from coaches guys
are left for their own devices i i feel
like maybe some players and again it's
not many in the grand scheme of things
but some players may be losing their way
because there isn't that chance for the
coaching staff and other members of the
organization to constantly remind them
of what they need to do to stay on the
right side of what the law requires
no no question about it not having those
group meetings not having the team uh be
involved and then not having even really
the involvement of their teammates and
their peer group so
it's too bad that you see these
incidents but you almost could figure
something was coming just with so many
players kind of on their own at this
point
and i think one of the realities is as
the teams have more meetings this week
moving up the agenda beyond learning the
playbook is going to be let's make sure
that we're dealing with these guys the
right way so they understand
how to make good choices when they don't
have that influence of their teammates
right there when they don't have the
coaches there hammering it into not that
it needs to be every single day but you
guys are young early 20s sometime with
temptation with downtime things can
happen and uh
it doesn't happen very often anymore
which i think is very good but this
little
flare-up that we've seen in recent days
hopefully provides teams with an
incentive to get things moving in the
right direction coach i thank you very
much for your time today it's great
seeing you it's great talking to you
very informative very insightful views
on the efforts to enhance the rooney
rule and expand and promote minority
hiring we wish you all the best and
can't wait to see you in person
hopefully sooner rather than later hey
thank you mike i appreciate it always
good to be with you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports